DID PRETTY MUCH ON HTIME. REALL
YEAR LONG.
IN FACT, IT STILL RANKS IN THE
TOP HALF.
NINE PLAYERS ON THE SIDELINE DUE
TO THE COVID PROTOCOLOL PLUS.
THEY PLAYED IN T T COMES O RILE.
DAVID PERRON, HIT THE POST.
FOR BY
>> BILLY DOESN'T EVEN REACT TO
THAT PUCK.
ZEGRAS, NINEO GET AWAY FROM MA.
THE DUCKS ARE QUICK TO GETN THE
RIGHT SIDE.
PASS THROUGH THE PENALTY KILLIN
WATCH IT GO OFF OF STICK OF
VAAKANAINEN.
NOW IT PERRON'S PURE GOAL SCORE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
PERRON AND HIS IN?
OH, IT DOES NOT.
IT FORMER MAPLE LEA BLUES TEAM A
TE
THERE'S SUCH A GOOD CYCLE TEAM
TO GENERATE A LOT OF CHANCES OF.
THEY GO TO C
THE RUSH.
HANDS IT OFF. GOING TO PULLEIGH.
NOT KNOWN FOR HIS OFFENSIVE
EXPLOITS.
NIKOLA, UP THE BOARDS.
HANGS ON
>> WE HAVAV
FOURTH AMONG DEFENSEMEN IN THE
ENTIRE LEAGUE.